Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and this is episode 10 of my personal journey.
And this is entitled Thoughts on Presid Reality.
So I've shared with you in the past that my present situation, my cancer from a statistical
point of view is pretty grim, but God is my father and it's all in His hands.
And does I struggle with that truth in everyday life, like we all do at different times?
God has been teaching me a lot of things, and I just want to share with you what He's been working through my heart with.
So I've got many responses as I've kind of come out of the closet by...
by my cancer journey here and shared with my colleagues what is going on.
I got wonderful blessed emails from so many of my friends and very encouraging.
I've gotten so many encouraging words from my patients, from my family, and I'm blessed by all of that.
But at the same time, the Lord has just been confronting me on that, on what His purpose is in this.
I've gotten lots of things like you can do it, or you're setting prayers for recovery, and I cherish those.
Please don't stop.
And words like you can fight the fight, this is your fight, you can win this battle, you can become a survivor.
I have faith in you, believe in your healing, setting me healing verses, setting me videos of people with success over terrible situations, not just cancer, but difficult battles that they've been in and how their willpower and their faith in themselves and their abilities have helped them to overcome.
And all of those are so inspiring. Think of the testimony you'll have, a couple people said me, that it's going to be fantastic, when you figure out the answers to this that nobody else has.
And those are all encouraging. And some nights, like tonight, it's late, and I can't sleep, and anytime this is my quiet time with the Lord, and I'll pull up videos and listen to some videos and watch some encouraging YouTube testimonials of people who had victory over cancer.
And I might have shared with you that a few weeks back, as I was struggling through this one dark night, where I couldn't sleep, and my pain was keeping me awake, and God used that.
His glory to wake me up and get me to study, and there was a friend of mine that had cancer a few years ago, and he had some videos out there and how he overcame the cancer and how his diet was how you beat cancer.
And there's videos out there of so-and-so beat cancer by going out of all vegan diet or all kind of ketogenic diet, and this is how you beat cancer, this is how you win the battle.
Look what I've done, look at the success that I've done, and that becomes their testimony, and that becomes who they are, and that becomes their battle cry, and that's the word that they go out with.
They have video series out there, they have testimonial series on how you can do the same thing and win this battle with cancer, and I think it's fantastic that they did that.
I'm not judging their call, but as I contemplated that, and I pray to the Lord, is this what you have for me, is this the reason why you have this, and you allow this in my life?
There's one thing that I can tell you without a shadow of a doubt that God told me he said that is not going to be your message.
That is absolutely not going to be your message son.
My father speaks to me sometimes, and I don't hear audible verbiage, but there's times I just know his heart for me, and his calling for me, and that's not my message.
I'm going to continue in these episodes to share what I'm doing and what has helped me, and that's great, and I want that to help people.
But I do know the deeper message that I'm supposed to bring is that regardless of our circumstances, it's who we are, and what God's shaped us to be, and what God's telling us to tell others.
That makes the difference. He gave me three points that I want to share with you.
And number one is, to clarify my purpose. I had to clarify, what is my purpose? What is my purpose? To conquer cancer, to have the answer, to tell everybody it's this new mushroom, it's the rife, it's this new therapy, it's this new supplement.
This is what's going to do, and it's the chemotherapy. Look at the victory that I have, so that I can wear that tattoo on my forehead, and the answer is clear, that's not it.
The purpose of everything in my life is one thing, and that is for my sanctification. That's a big word. What that means is to be molded and shaped to the image of his son.
And that's what his purpose is for me, and if you're a believer, that's what his purpose is for you, is to be molded and shaped to the image of his son.
Changed on a daily basis, though we sit and we fall short constantly. He's calling us back to repentance, and he's changing us and molding us and shaping us through our circumstances to bring him glory.
Colossians 3, 2 and 3 says, set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth, for you have died.
And your life is hidden with Christ. That's not about this earth, though. It's not about the temporal things that we call so dear to us right now.
What I want to hear is exactly what it says in the book of Matthew right here, when Jesus told the parable that his master said unto them, unto him, well done, good and faithful servant.
For you have been faithful over a little, I will set you over much, come and enter the joy of your master. That is what I want to hear, and that's what I want my life to count for, so that I can hear those words.
When I get to eternity, at first, this is what it says, and we urge you, brothers, and bodhish, the idol. That means encourage those that are kind of stuck in their faith, and are not moving forward, and are not growing.
Admonish them in a loving way, urge them on. That's what I'm doing this for. Encourage the faith-hearted. It's so easy to get discouraged in this world, and discouraged by our present circumstances, and we can't get faith-hearted, we can shrink back, help the weak, encourage them, lift them up, come underneath them and build them up. Be patient with all of them.
Verse 15, see that no one repays evil with evil, but always seek to do good to one another and to everyone. Rejoice always. That doesn't just say, rejoice when things are going our way. Rejoice when you have a good report from the oncologist. Rejoice when the pet skin comes out clear. It says, rejoice always.
Let's pray without ceasing. Give thanks in all circumstances. For this is the will of God in Christ Jesus for you. I can't be any clearer than that. What's my purpose? This is the will of God in Christ Jesus for you.
The Holy Spirit do not despise prophecies, but test everything. Hold fast what is good, abstain from every form of evil. That is a perfect definition that Paul gave us to the Thessalonians of what sanctification is. That we are going to be molded and shaped to the image of Jesus Christ.
And it's a work that happens our entire life. Secondly said, we need to clarify by identity. I need to clarify by identity. Who am I? Well, I'm a doctor, I'm a father, I'm a husband, I'm a wife, I'm a child. What are you? Are you smart? Are you intelligent? Are you trying to figure everything out? Are you a survivor? What have you labeled as your identity?
What is that that you're holding fast to as your identity? Well God said, your identity is that you're my child. That's all. You're just my child. And that's enough. That's everything. That's all I need to be. That is everything. That puts everything else to rest.
Because once I understand that I'm just a child of the king, sickness doesn't have any power anymore. The need to figure it out all starts to fade away. Cancer begins to lose its grip on me. The need to see all my dreams fulfilled starts to fade away. My goals and my dreams and my plans start to become pale.
In comparison, and I just want to please him. That's part of what sanctification is. He starts to strip away all these things that we've held dear so long, all these idols that we've held on to, that we've created in our life that defined us.
When they start to get stripped away, then it reveals who we are really hanging on to. And I know that I am not always living this out. I fail daily. And I know I often let fear creep in just about daily.
And I think that I've got to solve this and I've got to figure this out. I have got to be the strong one. That's who I am. I'm the dad. I'm this person who is born to be a dad and a leader and to figure this out and to beat this. I've got to solve this problem.
But when I measure myself against my definition of victory, that is the very definition of sin. Because I am depended upon me. And that is the original sin.
But God just prods me to repent. He gives me the ability to repent. He gives me a heart to repent. And He forgives me every day. And He calls me again just to climb back up on his lap and to cuddle with him. And He just reminds me that I am His little boy. And I am His. And that's all that's important.
Thirdly, He said, you need to clarify your story. In the book of Hebrews chapter 11 is the chapter of faith. Talks about Abraham, the father of faith. And it goes through the Old Testament, all the pillars of faith, we could say.
But down to 32 is it's rattling off all these pillars of faith. It says, and what more shall we say for Ty would fail me? It says the writer of Hebrews.
I don't have enough time to tell you of the wonderful things that Gideon did in Brock and Samson and Jeffith and David and Samuel all the rest of the prophets go to six. It would take a book to write all the wonderful things. How they were so faithful and God was faithful to them.
Who threw faith, conquered kingdoms. That's a victory. Enforced justice. Oh, that's where I want to be. I've obtained promises. I've had all kinds promises. Stopped the mouth of lions. I can't even imagine that quenched the power of fire, escaped the edge of the sword boy. That's what I want.
We're made strong out of weakness, became mighty in war, put forward armies to flight. Women received back there dead by resurrection. I need to see miracles like that.
But then as if the writer doesn't clarify all those wonderful things that he just wrote about there that through faith they had these victories, how I would define victories.
Strong out of weakness, power and fire. Received back dead from resurrection, obtained promises. Enforced justice, conquered kingdoms. He continues without changing paragraphs. The next sentence. Some were tortured.
Refusing to accept release, so that they might rise again to a better life. Others suffered mocking and flogging, and even chains and imprisonment. They were stoned. They were sotted too. They were killed by the sword. They went about in skins of sheep and goats' destitute, afflicted, mistreated, of whom the world was not worthy.
It's as if the author said, let's not define faith by the outcome that you define victory. Faith in God and God's faithfulness to us is measured in eternity, not in what we see here on earth.
That's the purpose of this passage, how he builds the people that saw wonderful things while they lived on earth being fulfilled.
And others were glad to suffer on earth because they waited for a kingdom to be fulfilled on the other side of this world.
We have to remember, God said, do not stumble on a worldly definition of victory. If my testimony to you is only as deep as what I define victory here on earth, that is no testimony at all.
What testimony is that, if I have why kids are cured by some wonderful thing I did, how does God get the victory of that? Well, I'm not saying that he can't.
So don't get me wrong. There's multiple stories, read them, of people that God touched and healed, and they defeated their giant here on earth.
That's fantastic. With the writer of Hebrews goes on to say, therefore said we are so surrounded by so great a cloud of witnesses, all these people in chapter 11 that he just rattled off those that saw victory here on earth and those that saw victory on the other side, let us not also lay aside every weight.
Everything that weighs us down here on earth, all the idols that we've created, all the desires, all our dreams, all our goals, lay them aside and sinbed which clings so closely and let us run with endurance, the race that is sent before us.
Looking only to Jesus, the founder and perfect of our faith, who for the joy that was set before him endured the cross, despising the shame and is seated at the right hand of the throne of God, that is our story, that is our purpose.
He says in 2 Thessalonians Paul writes, to this end, here's your purpose, here's your story, to this end, we always pray for you that our God may make you worthy of His calling.
How does He do that? Through sanctifying us and may fulfill every resolve for good and every work of faith by His power so that the name of our Lord Jesus Christ may be glorified.
May be glorified in you and you and Him according to the grace of our God in the Lord Jesus Christ, that is our purpose, that is our story, that Jesus Christ might be glorified whether it's in health, whether it's in sickness, whether it's in success, whether it's in financial hardship, whether it's that our family is all together, whether our family is falling apart, whether it's in great things that we've done,
or whether it appears that we have failed in everything that we've set our hand to, that God is glorified in our life and that we bring Him glory and we find joy in all of those things regardless of the word of the worldly outcome so that we don't confuse that peace, that is our story.
And I want that to be my story, so that when you look at my life, it's not, wow, he did this and this and this and he had victory, this and this and this way, but my victory is consistent and constant in Jesus Christ, not in whatever outcome takes place.
And that's what I pray for you.